i am curious like from from kind of a an
investment standpoint here like do you
think it's worth the united states
getting involved at that level
not not right now because it's 25 years
400 billion dollars with china
is it worth paying more than 400 billion
dollars no
iran's the day iran signed that 25 year
400 billion dollars we probably lost
iran for a few decades i guess i mean an
investment from a a blood and treasure
standpoint uh like the the sacrifice
that it would take for the united states
to actually get involved and and
overthrow the the regime it's not worth
it because the only way to be worth it
is in a following way
so here here's the only strategy again
i'm i'm not involved in any kind this is
just i'm thinking like a strategist
is you need
a a couple things in place you need a
trump-like personality
that is hurting china first
okay hurting china first
china has to feel the pain
then
u.s has to say
if you don't pull out of this deal with
iran
we're going to increase the tariffs to
40 percent
so then china says china the
announcement comes out saying china
pulled out of the iran deal for 25 your
phone a billion dollars
that's progress do you remember when
huawei do you remember the company in
huawei do you remember when every day
everything we talked about was huawei
huawei huawei 5g huawei what do you
remember that whole story communication
telecommunication and then one day what
does trump do with huawei
bans the phone
remember why we we were one of the
bigger markets they were growing here
they were exploding and then do you
remember the situation where the huawei
cfo
who happens to be the daughter of the
owner who in canada got caught you
remember that story in canada she got
caught and then she had dealings doing a
deal
with iran huawei was do you remember
this whole story or no vaguely taipen
huawei cfo canada iran huawei cfo canada
iran and tapping iran as well
can return to china admits helping
huawei conceal dealings in iran there
you go this was a story washington po
wapo what date was this national
security go up a little bit
uh do you see the date september 24 yeah
this is not that long ago this is five
months ago this is six months ago but
this has been going on for a while so
so the only way it would work
is if trump says
here's more uh tariffs here's more
terrorists here's more tariffs and then
china says screw this guy you know what
iran were pulling out then they pull out
then his next move would be
tariffs to iran then him saying no other
middle eastern banks can do business
with iran all the banks tighten up the
people get pissed off with the regime of
course they're going to blame u.s ford
and then at that time was like do we
want this regime to be here then they
revolt it's like a five-step process of
getting there but it won't happen
without china yeah
it won't happen without china so
if we get them
then we can do something with iran
rather than china what other country
from a business standpoint dealing
standpoint are invested in iran or or is
iran doing business with actively let me
ask you a question who do you think's
more this is a pretty weird question to
ask who's more reasonable putin or g
who's more reasonable i have an answer
it's not even close gut is telling me
putin it's not even close
i'm telling you it's not even close
that you think putin is more reasonable
there is no way it's even close
that putin is more reasonable than she
is
there's no way you're saying she is the
least reasonable person let me ask you a
question are you more worried about
visiting china or russia
china if i told you right now let's go
to moscow leningrad for a week for
vacation would you at all be worried
yeah i'd be a little worried about a
percentage
i get your point i'm just saying
let's go to china for a week and do vlog
or do videos do some interviews yeah you
probably if i told you right now hey you
know uh the center of houston rockets
invited us with ns cantor to go to
china to see how great the country is
i said how are you doing you'd probably
take vacation that week
you know what i'm saying you know but
the point being i think putin is more
reasonable so
who has incentives putin has to be good
with iran still not good but it's right
there so they're dealing they're between
caspian seeing them
everybody has to figure out a way to be
okay with that neighbor because it ain't
going away it's not like it's you're
living in a gated community there's a
terrible of a neighbor that is just a
mess and you're hoping one day they move
iran's not going to move countries in
the eu deal with them
and not not as uh
not
to the levels of because remember eu
individual countries to deal with iran
have to be
also held accountable to the other
countries in eu so you're almost one
major country so
i think it's very different than eu i
may be wrong than it would be in
countries that are closer to iran but
both countries have a level of
national pride that kind of trumps
everything else the way that the united
states used to have
you know and that's why they're they're
emerging as
i think you know countries that are
going to eclipse us sooner than later
you could argue that in a number of ways
china already has i think they're still
dependent enough on us
to where they they couldn't uh execute
certain things that they probably would
once they get to that point but um you
know but both of them i think are
uh while they're hardline guys and
they're you know
the the pride and
success of their country is kind of the
the pinnacle of what they base all their
decisions off of
both of them are also not dumb enough or
or so emotional about those
uh those principles that they have that
they're that they're not willing to look
at it no different than you did with
iran like you have a i think a natural
bias to want to see the united states
get involved but your
your non-emotional side says no you need
to do it this way first you know whereas
most people wouldn't do that and i think
from a leadership standpoint in those
two countries that's that's necessary
and that's why they they do the business
deals that they do and are as successful
as they are and executing them
but by the way it's
china compared to russia it's not even
close
china is a 100x like what russia is in
every way exactly and i don't even know
what the other than oil industry what's
what kind of industry does russia have
other than oligarchy and oil but vodka
the world's
good industry but china has is
in many respects like you said mike is
going to surpass united states keep in
mind they have 1.3 billion people
um russia
putin is way more has to be way more of
a
strategist you know xkgb
than
than uh she has to be i i wouldn't i
think they're both
very very capable in that regard yeah
but
china is at least like you used this
analogy before if there's if there's a
poker hand china at least has a flush or
a straight putin's playing with like a
pair of threes and he's like pretending
that he's got you know pocket aces he
doesn't have
the the the do you think he has economy
is one thing which you're right if you
want to show that real quick title to
validate uh
uh uh
adam's point david if you can put that
on the screen and zoom in even a little
bit more you see how big japan china is
japan is us is francis germany is italy
is uk is canada it's not find russia
i don't know their top ten and if they
are they're number 10 or 11 bottom right
you got to zoom in more four o'clock all
right zoom in look at right united
states 20 rushing all the way to the
right 1.65 trillion four times bigger
than norway
by the way where's south korea on this
tiny little south korea
i don't know if you could find it at the
top right okay 1.82 trillion bigger than
russia bigger than russia a little less
south korea has a bigger generation
flip this now go to uh
military world leaders with nuclear
bombs world leaders they're top of the
list no doubt but you got to realize i
mean that's that's like say something
you know look at that say something
china and i click on it too so you see
the rest go a little lower to see the
rest see if there's a leaders bulletin
on there okay check that out
all right so uh uh uh nuclear what do
you see uh
uh us's at the top i'm curious as to why
they're at the top because russia's both
of russia's numbers are higher go go
that's not a go go to another chart
because this wikipedia go to another one
go back
go back there's another one that shows
it's a side go a little lower
there's one that shows you just go to
images i'm sure if you go to images
it'll give you a graph
click on the click on that one right
there arms control dot org let's see
what that is
go a
u.s is 55.50 india is 156 look at china
350. they're third but russia is 20
times more 18 times more than what china
so
russia knows that they're decades ahead
by the time china catches a nuclear
warheads
you know world war three may have taken
place by the time they try to catch up
you kind of have to ask yourself though
i mean at what point does it not even
matter i mean to me 350 50 nuclear
weapons is still enough to kill
everybody on the planet it's who's the
crazy enough guy that can pull the train
is this one of those things where the
the best defense is a good offense or
the best offense is a good defense where
it's like uh yeah i mean the the the
fact that uh you know that all these
numbers even exist is is
proof of that is that it's it's a
deterrent uh you know i also find it
interesting the united states is the
only country that's actually used them
you know
but you know so for us to
to meddle the way that we do i think uh
you know is is a little
a little uh convenient or strange but by
the way the the india pakistan situation
that's going on i don't know if you have
any structure they said that's the most
dangerous border in the world they're
both armed nuclearly and they border
each other and they are enemies yeah no
i mean i i don't dispute that uh from
from that standpoint i mean i guess the
good news is it's it's at least there
you know as opposed to here not that i'd
want to see any any more nuclear weapons
being used but but you know i think back
to to pat's point is that
you know russia has a bigger thorn in
the side of of the entire world that way
you know like they're
they're more capable of causing bigger
problems i think at the drop of a hat or
in
in a heated exchange more so than
probably china from a military
perspective for sure from a economic
perspective they are below
a tiny country like south korea i mean
even militarily outside of of the the
newt capacity
they're not that capable uh i mean
they're nowhere near as capable as the
united states or china you know it's
just it's the the nuclear stockpile and
that's kind of the great equalizer i
mean nuclear weapons are kind of the the
firearms of
of of countries that way uh if you
kind of parallel it to say a 70 year old
woman with a with a revolver i mean like
the nuclear weapons gives people a stage
that's why iran is so hell-bent on on
getting them is because it it enters you
into a realm of respect internationally
that
just doesn't exist in any other way so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]